hey guys how's it going welcome back to
my kitchen I'm Justine and today we are
gonna be celebrating Thanksgiving by
making a festive turkey now I actually
planned on making a real turkey but then
I looked into how difficult it was to do
it and I said no we're not doing that
but I found this turkey this is a rice
krispies treat turkey and I don't really
have any directions but I have this
photo that I'm gonna go off of and I'm
gonna try to do the best that I can do
which is usually not very good so let's
start the first step is to make the rice
krispies treats so we've got some
directions here on the box I also try to
make things easier by getting some
marshmallow cream I've got our bolts got
our rice krispie treats we've got our
marshmallow cream that you can also use
a bag of marshmallows and we've got our
reese's pieces pieces pieces Reese's
Pieces to put inside of our turkey as a
nice little stuffing okay first step how
many cups six cups in microwave-safe
bowl heat butter and marshmallow on high
for three minutes
so we're gonna put the marshmallow cream
into the the bowl go here we go here we
go
I've made rice krispies treats many many
times in the past actually not that many
times maybe like two times in my life
three tablespoons of butter so I'm gonna
double this and that's six because math
is my strong point I know what you guys
are thinking justine this is not going
to work out and you know what I'm
thinking you're absolutely right keep
high for three minutes stirring every
two minutes one two three so I might
need to split this up and and use this
other bowl because I don't know what's
gonna happen I guess let's measure out
six cups of Krispies to really see what
we're working with here getting
concerned felt like I'm probably gonna
need some parchment paper or something
probably should get a dish whoa
it hasn't even been the full minutes yet
the smells really freaking delicious it
smells like butter and marshmallows it
smells good really good I got to take my
Apple watch off this is gonna get messy
too or
oh god I don't know what to do
everything is just
oh I'm starting to panic what what
Martha Stewart do well no I think I can
just put it all in here let's let's see
what out or just give it a good mix oh
god oh god this is I'm gonna spray my
hand with every mix portion of them in
here this is just gonna be a nice little
back and forth I think that's gonna
happen here
do you mixed up real good real nice ahh
Oh God trying to make this easier
freakin fire okay let's put them back in
here Oh spray my hands don't wanna get
stuck let's just see what we can do so
this is going to be the body of our
turkey so we are going to mold him very
very nice with our hands perhaps this
turkey we've already cut off his wings
maybe I'll just take this scoop and this
could be his little things
geez come on man that's his one leg this
will be his other leg this looks like
his body
it's like antibacterial soap but why use
some paper to do my molding okay there's
our turkey body he's looking real true
here's our turkey leg
this turkey had a lot of GMOs a little
too many GMOs for his bod and he started
getting mutations well I'm gonna let
this cool off and then we're gonna do
the carving of the turkey great idea our
turkey has been cooling for quite some
time and I think it's officially time to
stuff it and carve it so let's carve
first then stuff I don't even know which
side is the front I don't know which
side is the back but this looks like a
nice place to start so we're gonna cut
[Music]
oh gosh hey you got just
roadkill I think that's about as good as
we're gonna get now we'll just stuff it
I guess
here we going are you ready
yeah that looks good huh well I tried
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed the making of this
incredible Turkey if you guys want to
attempt this all the link in the
description where you guys can see a
better version of this and you can try
to make it for yourself if you do
they'll bring us up me a photo I'd love
to see you guys attempt this and in the
meantime I'm gonna go put this in a
container and save it for my friends cuz
at least it's edible Happy Thanksgiving
see you later